- You look for that thing that moves you.
At that point, I thought this is what I do
with my life, and nothing mattered,
being famous, being rich, nothing.
Only doing this.
Desire can sometimes trump talent.
- He's an American actor,
filmmaker, and screenwriter.
He's had an acting
career spanning 50 years,
and along that way has received
numerous awards and accolades.
His performance as Michael Corleone
in The Godfather is widely regarded
as one of the greatest screen
performances in film history.
He's Al Pacino, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Al is talking,
if he says something
really meaningful to you, please
leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it, so
others can be inspired as well.
- You look for that thing that moves you,
I don't know what it
is, I like repetition.
And as the saying goes, repetition,
repetition keeps me green.
I love that saying.
- [Interviewer] Repetition keeps me green.
- Keeps me green, fresh because the idea
that we do performances
over, and over again
you'd say well doesn't
that get boring or stale,
but no it's in repetition that
the creation comes, that the
expression comes because,
I'll give you an example,
I was doing Richard
once and not particularly well,
and this show is going on, and we couldn't
get this court scene with
a lot of people in it.
I didn't understand what
I was doing in the scene.
So, we would call rehearsals and I
would, we would rehearse it and stuff,
and we would talk about it, think about it
you know like all this kind of work
where people together are
trying to figure out something.
The 85th performance of Richard,
I had done it, my 85th entrance,
I knew the court scene.
I understood it, I was
there, I could play in it.
- [Interviewer] But not in 84?
- Not in 84!
I might've been getting
closer than realized,
I gave up the ghost, I guess.
I just gave it up and said oh, screw it,
it's not going to happen and
I'll just keep going on, and I found it.
All train compartment smell vaguely of,
I guess so you don't mind it.
That's the worse thing that I can confess,
you know how long it took me to get there?
A long time.
When you die, you're going to
regret the things you don't do.
You think you're queer, I'm going to
tell you something, we're all queer.
You think you're a thief, so what?
You get befuddled by
middle class morality,
get shut of it, shut it out.
Cheat on your wife, you
did it, live with it.
You little girls, so be it.
There's an absolute morality?
Maybe.
And then what?
If you think there is,
go ahead be that thing.
Bad people go to hell?
I don't think so.
You think that?
Act that way.
Hell exists on earth?
Yes.
I won't live in it.
I would like to be
someone who takes chances,
I think part of the adventure of it
is to go into something, and
not be afraid to screw up.
Because then you're
reaching for something.
Come on!
- Why are you doing this, Roy?
- No, I mean it, say it.
Say Roy Cohn, you are a homosexual.
And I will proceed, systematically,
to destroy your reputation,
and your practice,
and your career.
I think what happens is you
learn to forgive yourself,
because you see in the scheme of things
how it is, and you say well
gee, you know, I tried.
The worst thing, as they
say, is not to go for it.
But, if you go for it and it goes,
you know, it's out of your hands
and it's like that old saying what anyone
ever says about me is
really none of my business.
So, you know, you sort of you go
and you hope for the
best, and then you see
that a lot of the times, you know,
things happen and you
have no control over it.
Alright, let's get a message to Joey Zasa.
I respect what he's done, the new
overthrows the old, it's natural.
- How could you do business with this guy?
- I'm a business man, first foremost,
I want no further conflict for that.
- You can tell him for me that he
could live, or he could die.
- Vincent, will you shut up!
(loud thunder)
That's it.
Joey Zasa.
He can't be doing this alone.
Just when I thought I was
out, they pull me back in.
If you're going to make a movie, right,
the whole idea is that you make a movie
about something, and to be able
to make a movie about something you know
something that's sort of in
your wheelhouse, so to speak.
It's something that you relate to.
It's important because
making a movie is so hard,
it's very difficult to get a
movie together and, oh man.
You know, you've heard it many times.
But to have something
you feel you understand,
that's why I had a lot of
fun doing a movie I made
called Looking for Richard.
It was sort of about actors trying
to figure out how to do Shakespeare,
then people and everything else.
So it had a very visceral
connection to it.
Well, a movie, a book about an actor
going downhill and losing
it, and getting older,
and falling apart seemed very
appropriate for me, you know?
And I thought this is going to work.
The one thing that bothered me,
the one thing that stayed in my mind,
and I couldn't get rid of
it, that haunted me, was why.
Why would she lie?
What was her motive for lying?
If my client is innocent, she's lying.
Why?
Was it blackmail?
No.
Was it jealousy?
Yesterday, I found out why.
She doesn't have a motive.
You know why?
Because she's not lying.
And, ladies and gentleman of the jury,
the prosecution is not going
to get that man today, no.
Because I'm going to get him.
Everything I do, every day, every day,
whether they're working on
the play, the whole thing,
everything has to get to a point
where you don't have act it.
That all you're doing is
going through the thing,
and you're not acting it.
You just know what you're
talking about so much
that you don't have to act it.
If you know what you're saying,
you know why you're
saying it, and what you're
talking about, and who
you're talking about,
and how you feel when you talk about it,
then you don't have to act it.
And that's what the whole thing's about.
Alright, alright, that's enough.
I want 'em dead, both of them.
I want this no-face dead,
and I want Tracy dead.
What's a matter?
You bums forgot how to kill people?
Doesn't your work mean
anything to you anymore?
Have you no sense of pride in what you do?
No sense of duty?
No sense of destiny?
I'm looking for generals,
why do I got foot soldiers?
I want Dick Tracy dead!
Yeah, I often say to people who talk to me
about Shakespeare, who are not actors
or directors, who haven't
ever played it or done it.
The actor learns
Shakespeare in another way,
because he learns it having to do it,
having to spend months with it.
So, he approaches it in that way
and understands it in that way,
and the familiarity with the words
and the phrases, and what the content is,
what it's saying becomes a part of you.
And the revelations keep coming
long after you've closed in a play.
You know, you know things,
and you hear things
in a way that you could
never if you saw the play,
or if you read the play, no.
That's why actors, in a way, are lucky
that they get an opportunity to,
that's why some of the great ones
that had the repertoires
of plays they did,
so wanted to do it because
it had so much in it.
It's almost like, I can come close to say,
say you were a cello, you
played the cello or something,
and you were playing Bach on the cello.
I mean, wow, imagine that.
You know, so that manifestation
of spirit which comes out of it
changes you, it lifts your life, it does.
It gives you so much.
And once that appeal to me, when I
was very young actually,
I was a very young guy
when I started to do Strindberg
and things like that,
and was very affected
by that, cause I thought
here it is with this material,
it's like playing the cello
because I can kind of just express things
in myself, and it made
me sort of universal,
it gave me a more universal sense
of things and myself,
because I was doing things
that happened years and years ago.
I was out of the south Bronx.
I was out of the life I come from,
into another world that was
giving me all this stuff.
It was a gift.
And I knew from that point on, age 21,
I knew at that point I had been
acting since I was this big,
but at that point I though
this is what I do with my life.
And nothing mattered, being
famous, being rich, nothing.
Only doing this.
Now at 21, that's easy
to say you know, I mean.
There's just you and
pizza, so you're fine.
(laughter)
But, it is true though,
that did happen to me.
How many Ferraris you
sold this month, though?
- It's not relevant to this discussion.
- Freddie, the 80s are over.
Are you trying to tell me these things
are just walking out of the store?
- This is a Ferrari sir,
this is the finest piece
of machinery made in
the automobile industry.
- Well, if you like it that much,
why don't you sleep with it?
Why are you selling it?
- Listen, I'd love to accommodate you.
- If this car performs the way
I expect it to, you will
get a certified check
of 101,000 and change when you come
in here tomorrow morning.
- It's 109,000 plus 950 dollars, plus tax.
- Freddie, for you, 107 all in,
plus a case of champagne, go
with your leftover turkey.
What do you say?
Don't worry about the
boy, he drives so smooth
you can boil an egg on the engine.
When we bring the car back,
I'll peel the egg for ya.
Desire can sometimes trump talent.
Think about that.
So that you may not have as much talent
as you think you have, but if you
have the desire, your
talent will find you.
I never anybody over in my life
didn't have it comin' to him.
You got that?
All I have in this world is my balls
and my word, and I don't
break 'em for no one.
You understand?
That piece of up there, I never like him,
I never trusted him.
For all I know, he had me set up
and had my friend Angel Fernandez killed,
but that's history.
I'm here, he's not.
You want to go on with me, you say it.
You don't, then you make a move.
Cause I'm making the films myself,
nobody sees them of course.
But, I make them on my own.
I made them, in the old days when I
had it, I used to make
them with my own money.
And that was kind of
strange, I was accused
of being crazy for doing that.
And, I was.
But it was important for
me to learn film that way,
so I like it, I like to mix it up.
- That plane goes to Miami.
- Okay.
That's where I want it met.
- Mike, that's impossible.
They'll tune him over directly
to the Internal Revenue
Customs and half the FBI.
- It's not impossible.
Nothing's impossible.
- It would be like trying
to kill the president,
there's no way we can get to him.
- Tom, you know, you surprise me.
If anything in this life is certain,
if history's taught us anything,
it's that you can kill anyone.
I suggest reading, of course it's tough
reading books these days, but you should.
I really believe in it.
Actually cause, you know, the Russians
saved my life when I was
very young, like your age.
And doing plays, if you
can if you're actors,
because the plays are what, roles that
are challenge you and stuff
are really good for you.
Because also, you're
doing plays sometimes,
that ask of you a lot of stuff.
I mean it asks you to do more than some
of these roles we get cast for
that don't ask that much of us, really.
I mean if naturalism, we do it you know,
you do this, but the roles that ask a lot
of you is where you develop, where you
broaden your horizons, your imagination.
And what you learn from
this great literature,
I mean if you're a cellist right,
you're going to want to play Bach, no?
I mean, why wouldn't you?
You're a cellist, Bach wrote for you.
And eventually you want to play it,
you play anything on it, but finally
that's what you want to play because
that's going to get you the kind of joy,
the kind of excitement that
is going to change your life, really.
Changed my life, a lot
of the parts I played
as a youngster made me broaden my scope
and my understanding of things.
It's really important to
open yourself up to that.
City cop, right?
Robbing a bank's a federal offense.
They got me on kidnapping, armed robbery,
they're going to bury me, man.
I don't want to talk to
somebody who's trying to con me,
get somebody in charge here.
- I am in charge here.
- I don't want to talk to some flunky pig
trying to con me, what's he doing?
- Will you get back over there?
- What are they moving in there for?
- Will you get the fuck back there?
Get back there, what are you doing?
Hey, get over there!
- Go on back there, man.
- [Cop] Get over there, will ya?
- He wants to kill me
so bad he can taste it.
- [Cop] Nobody's going to kill anybody.
- Attica!
Attica!
My instincts, I always felt, were better
earlier in my life than they are now,
it seems as though sometimes I'm a
little bit blinded by the the attention
so I don't make correct assessments.
I'm a little bit influenced by the fact
that I'm not on the outside looking in.
I was fortunate enough
to have certain things
happen in my life, I mean it's luck.
It's really luck.
And persisting in a thing, you know.
What is that, he who persists in his folly
will one day be wise, and I'm not wise yet
but I keep persisting.
(dramatic music)
Mr. Simms doesn't want it.
He doesn't need to be labeled still worthy
of being a Baird man.
What the hell is that?
What is your motto here?
Boys, inform on your
classmates, save your hide.
Anything short of that, we're going to
burn you at the stake?
Well gentleman, when the shit hits the fan
some guys run, and some guys stay.
Here's Charlie facing the fire
and there's George hiding
in big daddy's pocket.
And what are you doing?
You're going to reward
George, and destroy Charlie.
- Are you finished Mr. Slade?
- No, I'm just getting warmed up.
I don't know who went to this place,
William Howard Taft,
William Jennings Bryant,
William Tell, whoever.
Their spirit is dead if they
ever had one, it's gone.
You're building a rat ship here,
a vessel for seagoing snitches,
and if you think you're preparing
these minnows for manhood,
you better think again.
Because I say you are
killing the very spirit
this institution proclaims it instills.
What a sham.
What kind of a show are you guys
putting on here today?
I mean, the only class in this act
is sitting next to me,
and I'm here to tell you
this boy's soul is intact.
It's non-negotiable.
You know how I know?
Someone here, and I'm not going
to say who, offered to buy it.
Only, Charlie here wasn't sellin'.
- Sir, you're out of order.
(slams gavel)
- Out of order, I show you out of order.
You don't know what out
of order is, Mr. Trask.
I'd show you, but I'm too old.
I'm too tired, I'm too blind.
If I were the man I was five years ago,
I'd take a flamethrower to this place.
Out of order, who the hell
you think you're talking to?
I've been around, you know?
There was a time I could
see, and I have seen
boys like these, younger than these,
their arms torn out,
their legs ripped off.
But there is nothing like a sight
of an amputated spirit.
There is no prosthetic for that.
You think you're merely sending
this splendid foot soldier
back home to Oregon
with his tail between his legs,
but I say you are executing his soul!
And why?
Because he's not a Baird man.
Baird men.
You hurt this boy, you're
going to be Baird bums.
The lot of you.
And Harry, Jimmy, Trent,
wherever you are out there.
You too.
(gavel pounding)
- Stand down, Mr. Slade.
- I'm not finished.
As I came in here, I heard those
words cradle of leadership.
Well, when the bough breaks,
the cradle will fall.
And it has fallen here.
It has fallen.
Makers of men, creators of leaders,
be careful what kind of
leaders you're producing here.
I don't know if Charlie's
silence here today
is right or wrong, I'm
not a judge or jury,
but I can tell you this he won't
sell anybody out to buy his future.
And that, my friends, is called integrity.
That's called courage.
Now that's the stuff
leaders should be made of.
Now, I have come to the
crossroads in my life,
I always knew what the right path was
without exception, I knew.
But, I never took it.
You know why?
It was too damn hard.
Now, here's Charlie, he's
come to the crossroads,
he has chosen a path, it's the right path,
it's a path made of principle.
That leads to character.
Let him continue on his journey.
You hold this boy's future
in your hands, committee.
It's a valuable future, believe me.
Don't destroy it.
Protect it.
Embrace it.
It's going to make you proud
one day, I promise you.
I don't know what to say, really.
Three minutes to the biggest battle
of our professional lives.
All comes down to today.
In here, we heal as a team
or we're going to crumble.
Inch by inch, play by
play til we're finished.
We're in hell right now, gentleman.
Believe me.
And, we can stay here
get the kicked out of us,
or we can fight our way
back into the light.
We can climb out of hell.
One inch at a time.
Now, I can't do it for you.
I'm too old.
I look around, I see these young faces
and I think, I mean, I
made every wrong choice
a middle-aged man can make.
I pissed away all my
money, believe it or not.
I chased off anyone who's ever loved me.
And lately, I can't even stand the
face I see in the mirror.
You know, when you get old in life
things get taken from you.
I mean, that's part of life.
But, you only learn that
when you start losing stuff.
You find out life's a game
in inches, so is football.
Because in either game, life or football,
the margin for error is so small.
I mean, one half a step
too late or too early
and you don't quite make it,
one half second too slow,
too fast you don't quite catch it.
The inches we need are
everywhere around us,
they're in every break of the game,
every minute, every second.
(team cheers)
On this team we fight for that inch.
On this team, we tear ourselves
and everyone else around
us, to pieces for that inch.
We claw with our fingernails that inch,
because we know when we
add up all those inches
that's going to make the difference
between winning and losing.
(team cheers)
Between living and dying.
I'll tell you this, in any fight,
it's the guy who's willing to
die who's going to win that inch.
And I know if I'm going
to have any life anymore,
it's because I'm still willing
to fight and die for that inch.
(team cheers)
Because that's what living is.
The six inches in front of your face.
Now, I can't make you do it.
You got to look at the guy next
to you, look into his eyes.
Now, I think you're going to see a guy
who will go that inch with you.
You're going to see a guy
who will sacrifice himself
for this team, because he knows
when it comes down to it, you're
going to do the same for him.
That's a team, gentleman.
Either we heal now, as a team,
or we will die as individuals.
That's football, guys.
That's all it is.
Now, what are you going to do?
(team cheers)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Dorian Wright asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of Al's
top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you, and why.
Leave it in the comments, and
I will join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout out
to Jason J-Ryze Fonceca
from ryze online dot com.
Jason bought another copy of the book
so I'm giving a quick shout out.
Thank you so much, Jason,
it means a lot to me.
For those of you guys watching,
if you want your chance at a shout out
in a future video, make sure
to buy a copy of the book,
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.
- Attica!
Attica!
I had this ability to mimic.
I would mimic the movies, I would mimic
any of the current singers, whether
it was Al Jolson, or
Sinatra, whoever it was.
And I then learned how to mimic
situations and people
just for the fun of it.
Where am I going to go?
A lot of us who are actors have that
sort of performer in us.
Cause she got a great ass, and you got
your head all the way up it.
Robin Williams would be the example
of someone who really lets you see it.
You know, most of us have it,
but we don't have his gifts
to be able to express it.
But the needs are there.
If you're a shy person, sometimes you hide
behind an image that you
think somebody has of you.
Say hello to my little friend!
(explosion)
It's almost a pose that you
can let your guard down,
or commit to anything.
And it's a way you can get into
the habit of doing that, I did for awhile.
- [Woman] Is it true?
- Don't ask me about my business.
Because, in a way, once
you start getting parts
your learning process is going to get
less and less anyway, cause you're
going to be given roles that
you are so-called right for,
quote unquote, which is type casting
which is a lot of bologna, and you're
going to get into that kind of thing.
And you're not going to get a chance to
grow and stretch yourself.
(gunshots)
Oh, nothing!
I used to use auditions
as a way of practicing.
What are you going to do about it?
Usually they'd have a script they
wanted me to read, I'd say oh I'll tell ya
I've prepared a little
something, you know?
What are you going to
do about it, asshole?
And it was an opportunity to do something
that I'd been working on, and you would
work it out without ever
thinking about getting the role.
I'm a journalist, think.
Use your head.
How do I operate as a journalist?
By screwing the people who could
provide me with information before
they provided me with it.
I used to dream about John a lot.
Of course, when it first happened.
And he was always alive in the dream.
See, it's always there, you know?
30 years.
I was doing a play called
Basic Training of Pavlo Hummel
on Broadway, and it
was a really great role
and I had done things with it, and I
had gotten the Tony Award,
and I was really, you know.
Elmer John was coming to see it.
And I don't like to know
when anyone's in the house,
but I knew John was in the house, right?
And every single thing
I did, every scene I did
I was trying to impress John.
And I knew I'm doing
this, I'm saying to myself
I'm not doing this, I'm
trying to impress John.
You know?
And, it was over and I was really unhappy
cause I knew I hadn't done.
And John came back, and he said
it was very impressive, Al (laughs).
Very impressive.
I went yes, John.
I said, you know what.
He said, he was so graceful though,
he was so gracious about it all,
but I said, you know,
I knew you were there
and I was trying to, I've
been doing everything
twice as much as I had to do it, you know?
He says, it was good Al, it was good.
It was good.
I said you don't know, you don't
realize that, you know,
you've been doing it.
But I knew I had.
So I was very, you know, he was like
one of my idols so that
when he was coming to see me
it was.
You give all out, and
that's the worst thing
you can do is try to impress
your friends who you love.
- What's the best direction you've
ever received on a set?
- The best direction, well
one of the best things
that comes to my mind now is this AD
Burt Harris on Dog Day Afternoon.
Well, he came up to me.
I was in the, first of all he
kept me sober every morning.
He hit me with those tomato juices.
I'd come in.
Some girl the other night was describing
knowing me in Godfather II, how I
came up with that crazy
hat and scarf, and stuff.
And then I would have
to turn into Michael.
Slowly it would just (groans).
(laughter)
And I'd become this.
But anyway, Burt Harris came up to me.
Smart kid, I mean, smart man.
And I was in the middle of stuff
and he just came over
and whispered in my ear,
which we were in the
dark, they were out there
with all the, I recommend the movie
on a big screen if you could ever see it
to see what Lumet does with a crowd
and with the street, and to put you in it
in such a way it just is kinetic.
You can feel the energy around.
It was a turning point in
films, and the way he did it.
But anyway, this guy Burt, Burt Harris
comes up to me, this is what
I love about movies, too.
And he leans in and he says,
say Attica.
I said, what?
He said go over the the crowd
and just yell out Attica.
Okay, remember Attica.
Because Attica was in prison and had had
a lot of trouble, and
terrible prisons were killed.
It was a real scandal,
it was so in the world.
You know, it was right there.
And I said, oh okay.
He said go ahead, you just go out there.
So I went out, and there I am,
and there's all these
extras out there standing
there all day long, and they start
looking and the cops, you know.
And I just say you
know, what about Attica.
At one point I just add
to the cup, I says Attica.
And I looked at the crowd, and I said
hey, remember Attica!
Huh?
Attica!
And they went yeah, Attica.
Somebody says Attica.
All of a sudden they say Attica!
Attica!
And this become an iconic
moment in the movies,
and that's how it came about.
- [Host] That's amazing.
- Isn't that something?
Yeah, I mean this is the way
these things happen in films.
If you're open to it, and that's
the kind of brain that Lumet had.
And we would do things like that.
And, you know, it just became this magic.
When you're out there, you got the room,
but when you're doing a movie
in six weeks, they don't
have time for Attica.